Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn is time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 18th, 2016.
How's it going out? Why?
Yeah.
Uh,
I am recording this Sunday
afternoon and, uh, in Vancouver,
Canada doing two shows here tonight.
It's halftime,
actually third quarter just started
of the Bronco Steelers. I missed, uh,
Seattle and a Carolina. I know that
must have been a great fucking game.
It kills me. You know, you
never know when your book,
the fucking gigs that have game
like that is going to be on. But uh,
I imagined that that was as
good as the score looked.
And of course I'm up here in Canada
and uh, I dunno, they don't have,
they just went to boomer and all those
guys at halftime and all they did was
interview Cam Newton. They asked him one
question, you know, he didn't answer.
He just talked, didn't give an
answer about anything. They like,
what do you think it did?
The, uh, the second half to,
uh, you know, uh, blah, blah,
blah. And he just goes, well, you
know, our offense and our defense.
And of course the special teams,
you know,
everybody's got a job to do when they
get out there and they tried to get done.
And unfortunately today we were able to
get out there and execute some of the
things we'll be working with
all this week. And uh, you know,
next week we've got another person
that we're going to be playing.
I should set a team, not a person who
we had on the team are going to play.
I know. We just hope that, uh, you know,
we're just going to try to keep
it going because, uh, you know,
we're all trying to win
a championship here.
Yeah.
And by then you're just like, what
the fuck did I even ask you? Um,
I wonder if, you know, cause athletes,
anything they fucking say they're going
to take it out of context. So they just,
they get trained to just answer and not
say anything. Just like a politician.
I wonder if you could fucking
turn that off. You know,
if you stay in the league long enough,
if you drive your wife and that's,
you know,
hi.
Well you know,
you're your own a lot of stuff at uh,
sometimes that stuff gets misplaced at Oh,
you can do is just try to fire on all
cylinders and try to find the things that
you could have in a, if you can
find them, you can find them.
And if you can't a then you've got to move
on to the next thing. But uh, you know,
it was always,
I'm always looking towards the next week
and then another thing that's going to
be lost in,
I've just lost,
while we're definitely going to do
everything we can to find it, uh,
the offense defense,
special teams.
Um, anyways, uh, yeah. So
I'm up here in Vancouver.
God dammit. It's fucking beautiful
up here. Fucking gorgeous man.
Especially when you live in, uh,
you know where the hell I live,
which was not designed to have really
anybody living there other than I guess
maybe some indigenous people
sending smoke signals, you know,
probably sending smoke signals said,
you know, can you find any food?
Cause we can't.
I'm sick of eating snake and do you
want to get the fuck Outta here?
However the fuck you do
that with smoke signals,
it must have been pretty God damn simple,
right?
The smoke signals if they even did it
or is that just another Hollywood thing
that they threw a ball? I mean,
how do you even fucking do that?
I guess she had to go. Obviously
you've got to put the fire out, right?
How the fuck would you do that? You
know? All right. One big pop for fucking.
She had to know what kind of wood to burn.
What a pain in the ass.
Jesus Christ you.
I'm going to get lost it.
I remember getting lost at the
mall before a fucking cell phone.
That was unbelievable. Forget about back
then. If you get lost or you are fucked.
Okay.
Anybody see a,
what the fuck was that guy's name?
Oh, fucking red face. Where the ego
done. I mean, how long do you look?
You can't really yell.
You're going to attract wild animals.
It's walking around the woods.
Hey Eddie.
Eddie the fuck are you.
This isn't funny man.
Anyways, but you come up here
after leaving the desert.
Um, whenever I see at the,
say the desert, I always think
of a that awesome. They're great.
Greg Giraldo rest his soul joke where
he says did that whole thing about, uh,
how eloquent the words, the
words, the notes were that, uh,
soldiers wrote during the civil war,
you know,
versus some of the letters from
people coming back from re Iraq.
Uh, what am I, I can't
remember how the it went.
It's really hard to be out here with
the ball sticking g leg out here in the,
in the desert.
And I remember the difference between
desert and desert. Two s's for dessert,
more calories. Right. There
you go. That's how I do it.
And don't even ask me to spell restaurant
cause I won't even fucking remember.
So anyways, I'm up here in Vancouver,
so we go to fucking land, um, and just,
Oh my God. All the lush greenery,
all the lakes, all low water,
everything we don't have down in La,
beautiful houses.
I guess it's expensive as shit up
here. And they were saying how, um,
a lot of Asian people, um, you
know, not indigenous foreigners,
you know,
they got to get rid of that fucking money.
They get to wash their money or
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Their government's going to take it all.
So they uh,
use this place up here like a Swiss
bank and they buy like super expensive
places for cash.
MMM.
Which drives the housing market
up. It's fucking nuts, man.
Anytime you go to another country you
just see the shit that they're fucking
dealing with. I just, you know, you always
think like, he come up here, candidate,
it's going to have no fucking problems.
You know,
you watch one Michael Moore documentary
that just gives you a complete like
misinterpretation of what the fuck
is going on up here. Um, so they,
I guess they had to make some sort of law
mmm.
That you couldn't do something like that.
I can't make him up.
The fucking person told them went all
the way while the way to the fucking
supreme court.
It was like a group of people from Asia
that was so rich that they actually sued
an entire country for not letting
them either come into the country or,
uh, by a bunch of shit over here that
drove the housing market and stuff up or
something that, or by their citizenship,
I can't even fucking remember.
But that's the charm of this podcast.
You know, I get a little information,
I barely remember half of it and I
just fucking run with it. That's all.
Um, so anyways, um,
so it went all the way to the supreme
court and then they would just finally
like, ah, yeah,
you kind of have to be from this
country for us to give a fuck about you,
you know, to like win a
lawsuit. So a, see you later.
And that's in an ended, I guess the
lawyer for them new the whole way,
going all the way up that it
wasn't going to happen, you know,
they weren't going to win it
and he just took that money.
He probably had to sit there and work on
is uh, I'm disappointed we lost to face,
you know, as he took all their
fucking money. But anyways,
so let's talk about NFL
football. What pop pop. Pop Gate.
A car. He didn't get it in.
Um, the fucking patriots.
They want God dammit.
Thank Christ they won then
Christ day one in Seattle.
Los Thank Christ. You know, if
we're going to keep advancing,
I just didn't want Seattle to get to
revenge. You can't remember if I've,
if I've already said this,
I just didn't want to see Seattle get
the revenge on a bagged up Patriot team.
If we come become healthy and they kick
our ass good on them. But uh, you know,
congratulations to the Carolina Panthers.
They gotta be the favorites at this point.
Come on this 16 and fucking one. Right.
Got that young defense then that scared
as shit. They just beat Seattle. Right.
Who knows? But, um, I don't
know shit about football.
I've just been so fucking busy, so
I'm, I'm still going to talk about it.
You guys can keep trashing me that I
don't know. Shit. I don't give a fuck. Um,
and by the way,
this is why I never record on a day that
I flew because my brain is even more
all over the place than it usually is,
especially when I got a fucking TV
going on in the background. But uh,
you know, I got, I got too busy
fucking datum. I fly back tomorrow.
You got a busy fucking day. So I
apologize if this is all over the place,
even more than usual.
I as a first down for this
fucking 25. Oh, somebody else up here.
It gives a shit about NFL football.
I know they,
a CFL ends and like is it the end of
November? They have the Great Cup,
which is their super bowl or
is it a December? I don't know.
The people even give a shit.
You ever see the fucking stadiums
for their football teams up here?
It's like you sit in the stands,
you can see your car, you know,
one of those deals where
there's like a fucking,
you watch them kick a field
goal and you're looking at
traffic driving by on the
street, like those old
school football stadium, uh,
from like the sixties and seventies.
You know,
where they would have like the horse
shoe shaped stadium, which was,
I think what happened with,
with the,
with the football stadiums was when
there wasn't that many people in the or,
and also the leagues were small. They
just had sitting on both sides, right?
He had the home side and the
visitors side and that was it.
And then as there's more and more
people population got bigger,
the league's got bigger,
then they built end zone seats
that connected both sides.
I think they just did it on one side
first. And he had the horse shoe, right?
Like the fucking Broncos
played in the buckeyes.
A buckeye still called their horse,
they still call it a horseshoe,
even all they fucking closed in it.
And then eventually there was people,
people did so much fucking that
they had to close, you know,
and there's so much ESPN
that got everybody fucking
interested in it that isn't
even interested in it. Then
all of a sudden Beyonce
singing it fucking halftime,
you know? I mean there's a bunch of people
in the crowd that are excited by it,
you know?
MMM.
A fucking old ass Rod Stewart
who the fuck they dragon out?
They always usually go
with somebody younger.
They just fucking drag somebody out
who's on their last fucking legs,
like their last big payday, you know,
they just fucking wheel him out there.
Who are they going to do this year?
Okay.
Uh, night ranger. Do you think going
to be like night ranger? A Drake.
That's what I'm guessing. Oh wait,
I think it is Beyonce. You know?
I know cause neo wanted to go to the
Superbowl because Beyonce was there.
I'm like,
why don't you go see her in concert?
Okay,
you're going to make us go to the fucking
super bowl and then we get to watch
her lip sync.
One fucking song.
How the fuck did Sean Penn
interview that drug? Lord,
how do you do something like that? And
the government isn't like, Hey, you know,
we're trying to find that guy.
Okay.
You know when you're just sitting
there palling around with them.
Yeah,
probably bought them like fast
times at Ridgemont high DVDs. Right.
For his underground layer.
Okay,
dude, I love Sean Penn as an actor.
But how are your fucking tree?
Are you that you're going to go
and interview that fucking guy?
You know I did.
I'm trying to think how many fucking
standup specials I would have to put out
before I could go. I would go fucking
interview somebody in like, well,
I guess Isis is actually fight, but
we're fucking with them toe. You know?
I would just say, I'm going to
walk in there with my microphone.
They're all gonna laugh at me and then
they're going to saw my fucking head off.
Are we going wars tie me to a chair.
Fucking torture me to death.
That's insane. Hey, good on him.
Okay.
Also, I don't understand. Is
it El Chapo? That's his name.
He sounds like such a gentleman.
Huh? El Che is a good chap. El Chapo.
MMM.
I don't fucking get it man.
What are you doing?
Why, why did he go down
there and interview that guy?
Okay.
And like how,
how,
how well does Sean Penn's do?
Okay.
That drug dealers on the run, he's on
the run from our government, right?
Isn't this the guy who escaped?
I don't fucking know.
You know what's going on is my fucking
Internet won't let me sign on so I can't
fucking see anything. I can't see
the fucking highlights. Nothing.
You know,
while I'm up here is I fucking got one
God damn channel and a bunch of Tim
Horton fucking commercials,
which is at Dunkin donuts.
See if I can sign on here is an El Chapo,
the guy that like that we would,
that keeps escaping from jail.
Set the Guy El Chapo.
Come on man. Come on. Ah, this
connection is untrusted. Okay.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
There's probably some psycho from
Alberta trying to hack in here.
That seems like their Texas to me.
When you're up here,
it's all fucking oil. Men and ranchers
and Shit. Um, and then you got admitted.
Okay.
10 it seems like it's nice.
You know what I mean?
Like that's they're like business hub.
You know,
I'm just totally judging these just by
doing like driving through and doing a
little bit of standup out here. Like when
I did stand up in Calgary, great people,
but fuck an animal's Jesus fucking Christ.
They were animals.
I don't know if it's cause the place
that we performed out there was like no
carpeting or nothing.
They were fucking,
I think it was coastal cause
it was bring your own beer.
Fucking animals.
I would never fuck with
anybody from Calgary.
Okay.
I saw the way they behave when they were
in a good mood. It's excited for a show.
Don't have a fuck with
anybody from Calgary
to Edmonton. It was civilized
category. Jesus Christ.
They had everything but a hooker
swinging from a swing. You know,
back in the old days with the salons
where they had the horse, you know,
way overdressed. Once again, it might
just be a fucking movie thing. So much.
So much of my history is, is
based on that. By the way.
I can't get on the fucking Internet,
but for some reason I could fucking, uh,
I could do it over the, uh,
I could do it on my phone.
Let me look up El Chapo here. Like
I said, he sounds like such a champ.
I just think like that English thing.
Chapo.
He's a Mexican chap.
How Mexico secretly launched a
crackdown after Penn met El Chapo.
El Chapo was finally captured again.
That was one day ago.
We'll el Chapo rat out rival cartels.
Corrupt officials.
It's gotta be a lot of stress.
Be In this El Chapo guy. Huh?
Joaquin Guzman.
Okay.
You know,
I got to say,
he looks like a Mexican Robert
Blake like during the Beretta years.
Now when he says, uh, yeah,
that's me who's also on the
phone and it starts laughing.
How else this is when you know
you lived a fucking crazy life.
This is just the front page of this
guy's for if you search this guy's name,
how El Chapo was finally captured
again, we'll el Chapo. I read those. Uh,
El Chapo Guzman.
Sean Penn talks about them.
El Chapo had erectile dysfunction
surgery while on the run.
It's nice to know we took a pitstop,
you know, guy takes care of himself.
How nervous was that doctor
working on that maniacs? Dick? Uh,
El Chapo speaks rolling stone.
Sean Penn has terrible regret
about meeting El Chapo. Well,
what did he think he was going to meet?
It's going to get some fucking
Sherry's berries. The Hud for El Chapo,
Joaquin El Chapo Guzman.
The truth about the jailbreak,
there's nothing here about, uh, an older,
wiser El Chapo puts out a little singer
Songwriter Jesus fucking Christ do.
You don't realize how fucking finished
we are. Just as, as, as, as a,
just as a race, as a race, as
humanity. So I'm trying to say,
she says people were fucking done.
Yeah.
You know,
rolling stone.
Rolling stone this month as
Sean Penn talking to El Chapo,
Leonardo Dicaprio's on the current cover
and they're billing him where he has a
plan to save the planet.
Okay.
What are we doing? What the fuck is
that government not doing that a list.
Fucking,
uh,
actors have to talk to drug
lords and try to save the planet.
I mean, there's got to be how many leaks
are in the fucking damn at this point?
I don't know about you guys.
That does not make me feel comfortable.
You know what I mean?
Boomer Esiason to, uh,
figure out how to cut a
fucking colonize Mars.
That's the next thing that they're going
to have in the rolling. Rolling Stone.
You don't know why the fuck
do I want to hear that?
Can I hear a scientist?
You know,
how about have a navy
seal interview El Chapo.
Okay.
I don't know, Bill, how would you shut
the fuck up? I, I will. I don't know.
I get unsettled. I get unsettled him.
I did. I have problems with digestion.
Um, I can't even remember what
the fuck I was going to look up.
What was I initially looking
up before I got to El Chapo?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Some of the stories on that guy.
Okay.
You know,
it's right up there with that fucking rod
Stewart rumor for way back in the day.
Remember that one? I think it was, I
can't even have rob Stewart over there.
Yeah, they find like a gallon
of ges and his stomach.
His stomach had to be
pumped, you know, a gallon.
He went to trader Joe's and butts.
I'm a fucking all natural organic fuck,
I'm sorry. Um, you got a gallon
of it. You know, you went to a,
was those, what's that place
where you buy everything in Bulk?
Okay.
Fucking whales. They're pushing
around those pallet jacks by Cheerios.
You gotta get a membership to it because
with a C it's not countries. What's the,
what's the name of that shit?
I ain't never go to the fucking place.
Once I had to go in there
and get a membership,
they wanted on this fucking information.
MMM.
Oh Christ. What the fuck is
it called? That coat check.
I'm never going to remember it.
You know what I'm saying?
It just kills the jokes bill when he
can't remember the fucking references.
It just, it absolutely kills it. Costco.
Hey,
what's the cost going?
But one of those big fucking a gallons of
fucking Jizz it on a dairy. Chugged it.
Anyway, so there's, here's something
on El Chapo, El Chapo. They said, uh,
I can't remember, like, just
fucking killed this person.
His whole family took their kids and
I just, why I don't believe it though.
He took his kids and then flew him to,
uh,
to Columbia and then throw him
off a bridge. It's like, really?
There's not any bridges in Mexico.
You never know what to believe.
But I gotta tell you when you go south
or the u s you do not want to piss
anybody off as far as I can tell.
That's some next level shit.
And I could say that because I just
read papers from the United States.
They, uh, that's just,
that's just next level.
Like,
you know,
you're mad at somebody and then you know
how you get your revenge is just some
next, I read that, uh,
killing Pablo one time,
I had to put the book
down like three times.
Some of the shit they just
said that the guy did not,
I don't know if the
fucking guy did this ship,
but I'm a one times hearing that the guy
had a party night and everybody's out
there by the pool standing around, you
know, and uh, what's his face there?
Pablo Escobar standing there.
You know,
everybody's ignoring the weight that
he's putting on as he sits there in his
fucking Hagar action slacks. You
know, you seem to like those.
He's stretched and, uh, you know,
still tucked them in right at the waist,
you know what I mean? Talk to him,
writing the waste. Didn't push the pants
down, didn't do the fucking shirt on,
tucked. He tucked it right in. And uh,
they said that he allegedly
filed one of his, uh,
one of the people they don't want to,
it's not as, but one of the maids,
I don't know what allegedly was stealing.
So they tied this guy's legs together
and his arms behind his back and they
threw him in the house pool
and just watched him drown.
Is everyone was standing
there at the party, you know,
I'd say they must have been a lot of ice
shaking and drinks after that one. Like
so is this a Victorian house?
Pablo?
Mr Escobar. Oh, I want to
go to the pool. Um, yeah.
People get their faces ripped off.
Is it torture or death?
They like peeling their fucking
faces back. This is not funny.
This is not what this podcast is about.
Um,
why is this fucking stealer
Denver game so fucking boring?
Yeah.
Is it, cause I have the sound
down. I just don't give a fuck
the afcs just the walking wounded
Rothenberg is a fucking man. Look at
that guy just getting bumped by Lyman.
He stays in there. That
guy, he has like fucking,
he stays in the pocket like Steve
Grogan use to use to stay in the pocket.
Did anybody remember that?
Any old pats fans out there?
You'd fucking sit there and say,
this is back when you could literally,
you could hammer a fucking quarterback,
drive your helmet right under his chin
and then lift them off the ground and
pile.
Drive them into the fucking astro turf.
Yeah.
Which is like getting tackled in
a parking lot that's been, uh,
painted green and Steve Drogan.
But he would go back for a pass.
It's back when he had that fucking
neck brace and he had such a long neck,
he could still see like six inches of
neck. Right. Even what the neck brace,
and there'd be some defensive lineman
just running full speed right at him.
And he, he would just hang onto
it, hang on to it, hang on to it,
and then he would throw the ball and
the camera would follow the football.
And right as he let it go,
you'd see just the beginning of that
fucking Lyman drilling them and he'd go
flying right out the right side
of your screen or left side,
depending on which way he was going
down the field to Stanley Morgan,
you know, Bruce Francis, one
of those fucking guys, right?
Harold Jackson.
Who else did we have back then?
I can't even fucking remember.
Okay.
Hasselbeck it Hasselbeck whose
son was the one who said, uh,
we want the ball and we're going to score
don Hasselbeck.
I think it was his dead. All right.
Anyways, what, where the fuck am I?
Um, yeah, Rothenberg is like that.
That guy stands in the pocket.
It takes a fucking hit
and speak in which to, uh,
I know there's a lot of Kansas City fans
would probably pissed off at the calls
Tom Brady got and the lack of call said
Alex Smith got Ed. Uh, I'm a patriots fed.
Uh, you're absolutely right, but
that is not Tom Brady's fault.
Okay.
And I'm hoping most of you guys at Kansas
City can hear what I'm saying because
you're not as upset because you got to
see your baseball team when the world
series. Right? So you
got that going for you.
Half of you professional teams
won championships this year.
That's pretty fucking good. Right? Um,
Tom Brady earned those
costs. Okay. This is the,
if you want Alex Smith to get
those calls in the future,
in the future,
he has to make the NFL owners
a lot more money than he is.
And that's just a simple fact. And,
uh, people call it the Tom Brady rules.
It isn't, it's the superstar rules. You
know, Jordan gets away with the push.
Right. Was the last time you Coby Brian,
what does Colby Bryant have to do to get,
you know, well, he's not healthy anymore,
but back in the day you could be standing
in the lane before the fucking game
starts and if he runs into you that
they're going to call it on you,
he'd literally have to take,
he'd have to fucking tie an ax to the
front of knee and fucking jump into your,
cut your head off before, you know,
there was a way to call offsetting.
They would have, it's just,
it's just how it works. But, um,
I have to say as much
as he earned the calls,
that one where he was getting sacked
and he switched it to his left hand in
throw it and they still gave him
the call was fucking ridiculous.
I even as a page, it's fair, I was
at hall going, Oh, what the fuck?
Give me a break, but
you know, I'll take it.
Of course they'll take it the same
way you would have. Uh, but uh,
I don't care to see as a great team
and they have, you know, Alex Smith,
I think he's going to be a
really fucking great quarterback,
but you got to have it all,
man.
He got to have the coach and the
ownership and all that bullshit and lucky
enough that we have that in, uh,
in New England. So there you go.
That's me trying to not be a cunt.
All right.
And uh,
Oh God, I can't wait to go home and watch
that fucking Carolina Panther game, man.
I think you're going to see like all
these people that they were saying or the
heir apparent to fucking Tom
Brady and Peyton manning.
I think it is. I think it's what's
his face there and the panthers.
I kid, you remember his fucking name?
What is wrong with me? He went to Auburn,
right? He's a superman thick
cam Newton. There we go.
MMM.
Anyways, that'll let you guys know this.
I'm supposed to read this shit here,
but of course I get up type of my fucking
password, which takes forever. Um, ah,
for fuck sakes.
I got to have a fucking 20 letter
password numbers cause God knows everybody
wants to break into my computer and
read my Dick Jokes here. Um, oh,
Andrew asked you guys,
he said,
please ask the listeners to put relevant
subject lines in their emails if they
want them.
Red Putting Hay doesn't help
with a thousand thousands a week,
trying not to miss any of
the good ones. Thanks. Um,
I probably could have nice
and that up a little bit.
He's sorta texted me that really
quickly. Um, yeah, so if you,
if you guys have a subject, whatever,
uh, you know, anything, you know,
fuck Tom Brady, Tom Brady rules
or something like that. You know,
if you just do that instead of writing
like, hey.dot, dot and then in the email,
be like, what the fuck was with those
calls? You know what I mean? Oh bill,
we get it. And if you want to send an
email that could possibly be red, uh,
or whose kid and Ho stumbled upon by me,
please send it to bill@themmpodcast.com.
Also, if you'd like to follow the
Monday morning podcast on Twitter, um,
it's at the m m podcast. Um,
all right. And with that,
it's time for a,
my attempts at reading out loud.
All right. Dollar Shave Club,
Everybody Dollar Shave Club, you know,
lots of players will be sporting playoff
beard now that the post season is here.
Uh, leave that to the pros. All right,
kick off your year the right
way with a fresh blade shave.
That's why millions of others have
joined dollar Shave club.com dollar shave
club knows the key to getting
an amazing shape is simple. One,
use a fresh doll shape called blade to
use their Dr Carver's. Easy Shave. Bye.
That's it.
Those shave club delivers amazing razors
right to your door for a third of the
price of those greedy
mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switched now
can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and
save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh blade
with their doctor, KVCC shave butter,
it just glides.
It's unimaginably smooth.
Just imagine the smoothest thing
ever and it's smoother than that.
You can't even imagine how smooth it is.
I'm telling you,
it's not your average safe foam. It
shave foam, it won't dry out your skin.
The all natural ingredients.
Leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized after every shave.
Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club. Play
with, talk to cabbies. Easy shave butter.
If you want the most gentle
shave imaginable, dollar
shave club.com/bird today,
join that. Uh, it's dollar
shave club.com/birth. Sorry,
I went a little light with the Dr. Carver.
He saw,
I'm in a hotel room right now and I don't
need anybody knocking at the two, uh,
um, 13 and nine. What's going on here?
The a Broncos are knocking on
the door here in the red zone.
Uh, who do you like? Odl? Like,
I think the Steelers are going to
win this one. I just do. I think a,
I don't know why. I just think that,
that, that they're going to win here. Uh,
of course you don't know why, Bill, you
barely watched any football this year. Oh,
by the way, congratulations
to the Alabama Crimson tide.
I can't believe I forgot to, uh, you
know, give them a shout out there.
Fucking a Nick Saban Five,
count them five NCAA
football championships.
I mean, this guy's like beyond a
fucking legend. Beyond the legend.
Unbelievable game. Uh, congratulations
to Clemson for getting there.
I hope you guys get back again. I
was rooting for Clemson. Of course.
Just cause it's fun to root against
Alabama. I don't really hate those guys.
It's just fun to root against them because
you know who I just don't like pilot
on anybody can just become a college
football fan of just root for the best
fucking team. I don't want
to do that. Right. And uh,
that fucking onside kick
call fucking tremendous.
What a call and the way that they hit the
whole thing though, that was the game,
right? They're unbelievable. So anyways,
here we go. Plowing ahead. Uh, me undies.
Oh Jesus. Oh Geez. But
I'll boop, boop me undies.
These Mandy's dry and your balls in
2016 Boudou due to be undies me undies
grabbed my balls and see what I mean.
They're nice and dry.
Take that look off your face. She
liked my balls. No matter what though.
Race put on me undies and dry.
We'll get tanked.
And they even make them farther ladies.
Oh yeah, they'll dry out. Fucking clam.
Even if you're in the mood. Um, me undies.
What's the secret to the
two New Year's resolutions?
Make the first step real easy. Uh,
like the first thing you do every day.
Put on underwear.
This year I,
with the old in with the news step into
a fresh new pair of me and he's the
world's most comfortable underwear and
it's the easiest resolution you could
make.
Head to me,
[inaudible] dot com choose from a variety
of styles in limited edition patterns
for both men and the fuck in late. And
they'll be delivered right to your Doula.
Me undies is the next level of underwear.
You thought your Dick was comfortable.
Now where do you take waiting?
It take you a balls to the next level.
Every pair is made with
their signature modal model.
Mill fabric proven to be
twice as soft as cotton.
Where,
where did you prove that at the x games.
Like all they say that like he could,
you can do research and
find that out anyways.
They don't just feel better
than regular on these. Um,
they make you feel invincible.
What are they under Roos
and you're eight years old.
Come on and it's guaranteed be the most
comfortable underwear you've ever worn
or your first pair is free.
So start your New Year's in.
Don't start your new year's
out with old saggy underwear.
Make it change and head to [inaudible]
dot com slash burr right now and get 20%
off your first order.
If he don't like your relationship and
you want to take back ground that you
gave away, the only way to do it is
to get brand new underwear. Okay.
Cause once you're
comfortable with somebody,
you walk around half an a nude anyways.
Right?
And they're not going to take you
seriously if you've got holes in your
underwear with pubes sticking out,
like some sort of fucked up vegetable.
All right? It's disgusting. Um, anyways,
plus shipping is always free for
all the orders in us and Canada.
So for 20% off your first order of the
world's most comfortable underwear,
it had to be on [inaudible] dot com
slash bar right now. And lastly,
but not leastly, uh, all going,
they kept the horse from the old Mile
High Stadium. I went to a game there,
I told you that, right? stamps.com
one great resolution. Sorry,
I'm watching TV here. One great
resolution you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar of your small business.
I know an easy way to do that.
Actually I don't,
stamps.com is telling me about it.
Think about how much time you've wasted.
Go into the post office driving.
They're finding parking,
not scoring any coke,
right?
stamps.com is the better
way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your computer and your printer
to get official US postage. Uh,
the fuck is Jim Simpson.
Man just died.
He had a great run 89
years. Good for him. Um,
everything you would do at the post op,
she can do right from your desk with
just a fraction at just a fraction of the
cost of one of those
expensive postage meters.
I use stamps.com anytime
of selling posters. I'm a
moron if I can figure it out.
So can you,
it's so convenient.
I can do it right for my home standing
in my brand new fucking me undies.
How you liked that, huh? Right now.
So this is like an advertising threesome
here right now or a twosome right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name, birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer.
That of course includes postage
and a digital scale. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B u r r and mercifully, that's the end
of me reading out loud for this week.
MMM.
Here's a stat I had to look up
because dom I rera sent me a a
yeah,
a text.
Okay.
I try to drop names here. By the way,
I'm on his podcast this past week. Uh,
Dom Iros sent me a text this morning.
He goes,
how many quarterbacks have
you ever seen in the NFL?
Okay.
Have a hail Mary pass throw if successful
Haman Hail Mary pass once in their
career.
Forget about twice in the same season.
And uh, I had to go look it up. I was
like, I gotta I gotta find this out, man.
I got to find out, uh, you
know, if anybody's ever done it,
cause I was like,
there's no way anybody's done it.
In my lifetime of watching the last 30
something years of watching football,
holy fuck. I've been watching
football for 38 years. Oh my God,
I'm old.
Okay.
I started watching it
religiously in about 1978.
Um, yeah, about that. 78, 79.
Jesus fucking Christ. Um, put it this way.
The first Superbowl I watched was
super bold 12th and there is 50,
so there you go. Wow. This
is going to be my, uh,
okay.
Well would that be my 50,
not 51st? You fucking idiot.
My 39th Superbowl 50 minus
12. Plus I watched 12, right?
Yeah.
Yeah. So that day. There you go. Yeah,
there's a lot of people right now
actually think I'm wrong, but it's true.
This is my 39th I'm going to be watching
anyways. Let's plow ahead here. Um,
so I looked it up. Successful
Hail Marys. Okay. Um,
there's only one guy that I saw since
they started keeping the stats in 1975,
at least on Wikipedia. I didn't go to
the football reference.com which I love.
MMM.
The one guy who's ever done done it
twice since they kept the stats in 1975,
Steve Bart Koski,
Steve Bark Koski and there's no way to
picture Steve our Koski and not have the
song,
this song go through your head
walking on a never thought
I could be so free.
He throwing the ball to Bailey,
watch,
choose Johnson and to another guy.
Yeah.
He looked like the greatest American hero.
He did it in 1978 against the saints.
And then he did it again in 1983
against the 40 niners in the NFC west,
which back then was only four teams.
It was the Los Angeles Rams,
the New Orleans saints,
the Atlanta Falcons,
and the San Francisco 40 niners
quarterbacks or Steve Bark Koski,
uh, [inaudible] 78 seat bark
house. He, Archie Manning.
Yeah.
And I think they had a quarterback
controversy. Pat Haden,
Vince Ferragamo back and forth,
uh,
for Vince covert gum. I tried to take the
money and went to the fucking CFL. Oh,
Jewish. Never saw him again. And, uh,
it would be Steve to
Burger Jim Plunkett at 78.
I did this with fucking
Joe Bart. Nick, one time.
We tried to name all the
starting quarterbacks in the
NFL in 1978 we went around
the league. I, so I think it
was a AFC east was Burt Jones,
Bob Greasy,
Steve Grogan,
Richard Todd and Joe
Ferguson for the bills.
Okay.
Then it was Terry Bradshaw,
Dan Pastor Reni.
Okay.
Who the fuck was quarterback for the
browns? It was either Mike Phipps or,
uh,
Brian's site.
And then the bangles was Kenny Anderson.
Kenny the candle
as Collins were sent.
They Call Him Kenny the candle,
cause one blow and he was out.
You ever see that one on NFL films and
they cut the Kitty Anderson. He's like,
I'll fuck Collins worth.
Um,
and let's see, it was Craig
Morton. I'll just do the AFC,
cause I know this just fucking drive
and everybody not split it. This is my,
if I have to do it now, because
now it's in my head. Craig Morton,
was it the orange crush Broncos.
Ken Stabler.
Kenny Snake Stabler for the,
uh, the Raiders. Dan Fouts,
the Great Dan Fouts Air
Corre l with the gadgets.
Yeah.
Jim Zorn with Seattle and then a fuck.
There's always the one that gets me.
Who the fuck was with the chiefs?
It was before black lynch
was after Len Dawson.
Who the fuck was the quarterback?
There's a good one for you.
There's some poor bastard in Kansas
City right now screaming it. Yeah.
Who the fuck was it? I even know, I
think like the Buccaneers had Gary hough.
Lynn Dickey was out in Green Bay.
Jim Hart was it? How the
fuck do I remember those? I
remember Kansas City, Kansas.
See, I gotta look this up. Kansas
City chief quarterback. Hey,
it's going to get better guys.
I played drums this week
out and I played with, uh,
Colin Hay from men at work, right? I'm
going to tell a story in a second here.
Just fucking deal with this here.
Kansas City chiefs,
Qb 1978.
Why do I care?
Why do I fucking care?
Lists of Kansas City chief quarterbacks.
This is fucking made for me.
Who's the last person who fucking went
to this starting quarterback season to
season Jesus. They've had some guys. Yeah.
Joe Montana. Warren Moon. Rich Gannon.
Yeah.
All right. Here we go. Here we
go. Back. Ended up backing it up.
Okay.
1970 I, I'd never get this.
Mike Livingston and Tony Adams.
This is the one that
always fucking gets me.
Yeah.
Lenny Dawson left in 1975 and
then Mike Livingston took over.
Okay.
You know,
there was a guy who played for the
Bengals that Bill Walsh was talking about.
He only played for one season.
He got fucking injured.
And Bill Walsh to this day still said
he's the greatest quarterback that he ever
coached, but he's probably still
trying to motivate or he was, anyways,
he passed away, probably still trying
to motivate fucking Montana or young,
even after they retired,
get them to rake the leaves
better that day or some shit. Um,
I can't remember the guy's
fucking neighbor. That's
one to look up. Uh, anyways,
so yeah,
this,
this week I did a Greg
Behrendt show at Largo and uh,
it was one of those things too. It's
not quite like the goddamn comedy jam.
This was one where they
actually have people, uh,
for the most part it's musicians
coming out and telling funny stories.
And this is something that Greg
did a number of years ago and, uh,
he's brought the show
back. And, um, so anyways,
let me, let me get the line up
here so I don't fuck this up.
I did take a picture of it. I'm so fucking
disorganized. I apologize. Um, all right.
So it was Colin. Hey, Tom Morello, myself
and Chris Fairbanks and other comedians.
So it was two comedians and then
a two musicians. And I got to a,
I got to play with the band,
told some stories,
and I got to play with the band.
And then afterwards I got to play
with Colin Hay and we played, uh,
who can it be now, which was a just
beyond a fucking thrilled. And he,
he was the nicest fucking guy,
so generous to let me play. Um,
then he had this really cool way that
he wanted to bring me out. He goes, uh,
he just went out there and he's telling
stories. He was fucking hilarious.
And then he just randomly goes, you know,
and I had the weirdest dream last night.
I was dreaming,
I was playing a show
and a, I was playing, you know,
who could it be now in the crowd
collapse because it's such a huge hit.
And he goes, the weirdest
thing, you know, it, Bill Burr
was on drums, like, you know,
and I just waited a second.
Then I just walked out and sat down.
Everybody started laughing and
then he told this great story.
I'm not going to repeat the story.
Just it's his story.
So I'm sure if he wants to
tell it on a podcast, he kit,
but he tells his fucking hilarious
story that ends with the word cunt.
And he told me after I say cunt,
basically you do the drum fill intro
and then we'll go into the song and uh,
let me play it anyway. And I went off,
went off pretty good man. It actually, uh,
I don't know. It's fucking unreal, man.
I played like 20 years by myself in a
rehearsal space until it finally dawned on
me that I'm supposed to be out
interacting with other fucking people.
So now then I've kind of opened
Pandora's box. I just, I told you,
I made this rule that I'm
not going to ask to sit in,
but if somebody asks me to play, I'm
going to fucking play. All right.
That includes if I come to your
town and if I'm drinking at a bar,
if I go out to a bar and
your local band is playing,
if you come up to me and asked
me to sit in with your band,
I'm going to fucking do it. All
right. I know. And this is a warning.
It's a warning. I'm going to do it
and I've got to fuck up. So you know,
if you want a story, I'll fucking do
it because it's fun as hell to me.
And it's weird. I don't feel
any pressure whatsoever because
I'm a comedian. Well, what's the pressure?
He's going to sit down and play drunk.
She's going to stick. Of
course he is. Everybody already
knows it, so it's fine. Um,
plus everybody just looks at the singer
anyways, but it's, uh, it's a lot of fun.
And I've been getting cycled
back into lessons and, um,
I told you I've been taking, I've
been taking some lessons. Um,
do you remember long time ago when I
watched that Mars Volta Video and, uh,
I was talking about that drummer who
was Dave [inaudible] at the time.
I was going, Holy Fuck, look at this guy's
fucking unbelievable, blah, blah blah.
Well, from doing that, he
must have heard the clip.
He reached out to me on Twitter
and Lo and behold, he lives in La.
And every once in a while I go by and
I take a lesson with the guy and uh,
he's a fucking unbelievable teacher and
he's been teaching me technique. So my,
you know, I'm one of those guys, I
grabbed the drumsticks the same way,
like a toddler would,
would just my fit meaty fucking fist,
just right over both of them and it was
causing my arms to be doing all the work
and my forum,
if ain't drummers are listening to this,
if you have like that fucking,
you know,
that pain in your forums and
all that, you know, that's,
I was kinda going through that shit and
he is teaching me this technique where
you let the stick do the work and it's
holding it in this particular way that
does not seem fucking natural at all.
And,
uh, it has been a motherfucker,
but you know, incrementally,
I've been gradually working
its way into my playing and,
uh, it's been, it's totally been worth it.
And we've been going through this
jazz book and I'm like most students,
like I work on something for three
seconds and then want to go onto the next
thing so I can have that
sense of accomplishment and
just get through a whole
fucking page and a, and I was moving
ahead and every time I'd go to the lesson,
I would still not have the,
the first thing down.
Okay.
And I've been taking lessons, you know,
on and off since the summer. I mean,
I get busy and I can't go for like
a month or something, but, um,
I'm still on that first page and it
finally dawned on me in the past week that
to be like, dude, just work on this one
fucking thing and fuck everything else.
And I just sort of sat down 15 minutes
a day just working on this thing.
Um,
okay.
You know,
make it a little bit of an improvement
and then being fuck having to start over.
And Blah, blah, blah, Blah
and all that shit. And um,
I actually had a great lesson this week
where I think he actually was saying
that I was just,
I was finally starting to improve,
which made my fucking
week. So anyways, um,
I even know what the fuck I'm going with
this. I'm rambling all over the place.
What are we up to here? 45
minutes. Jesus Christ. Bill,
can we fucking get on with
this here? Um, oh, by the way,
somebody told me to watch the
show. Top boy, TLP boy on Netflix.
Yeah.
And uh,
I want to Netflix for the life I can,
I can figure out how to search when
I'm on the Internet. I can't fuck it.
Do it when I'm on the TV. I don't know.
How do you search when you were on the TV?
If anybody knows? I would
really appreciate it. But
anyways, I'm going to be, um,
I'm going to be a playing
out again this week. Uh,
I'm doing that Bonzo bash thing.
I'm hosting the Bonzo Bash Co hosting
and I don't even know who I'm co hosting
with. It's going to be an Anaheim
this Friday night. And, um,
uh,
Brian Tish,
she's wonderful event or all these dramas
that I grew up watching sit down and
play led Zeppelin songs,
which is going to be the shit I'm going
to get to host it and a with somebody
else. It's going to be
fucking awesome. So,
and I will be sitting in
for one song once again,
risking total humiliation, which, you
know, I'll probably make an ass of myself.
Who gives a fuck, right?
Um, but anyways, uh,
oh,
I knew what I wanted to talk about.
Yeah.
Fucking the Arizona cardinals packers
game. I started to talk about it and uh,
you would think last week after watching
that dude on the Bengals intercept the
ball and then fucking walk into the locker
room like, well, I guess that's that,
right?
You'd think that these,
these damn kids today, they'd
learned something. Patrick Peterson,
who I fucking love Lsu Kid,
right?
It didn't complete fourth down.
That ought to fucking do it.
Two and a half minutes left.
This guy's walking down the
sideline waving to the crowd,
doing damn near blowing kisses.
To the crowd. Like it's over.
What he's playing pack is
in Aaron fucking Rogers.
Fucking hilarious.
Two and a half minutes of football left
and he's walking around doing that.
And what happened?
Two minutes and 25 football seconds
later he gets beat on a jump ball in the
fucking end zone on a hail Mary
to send it into overtime. Um,
fucking unbelievable. How many times
is somebody going to fucking do that?
How many times are you going to run
down the field? You got the football,
you're not past the goal line.
You already start holding it out.
It don baby slaps it out of your
hand or you're fucking, you know,
you have to be a spike. It over
the, you know, over your back.
You know that one we had throw it down
over your shoulder and you get big toes
across the end zone,
but the ball is,
and how many fucking times you're
going to see people do that.
I just don't understand why I don't get
it. So anyways, let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
all right here.
So the questions are the letters for
this week. All right. Pasta bill,
if you want to get good at making pasta.
Of course I do begin with a genero
control those videos on food tube.
All right. I don't know if I
said I'd probably just say right.
It's g e n a r r o and
then the last name is c.
O. N T. A. L. D. O. S. No, d. O.
Apostrophe s can tall dose.
Uh,
the guy taught me so much I even
wished him a happy birthday. Uh,
also pay attention to sorts of flour
you're using cheers to you and your
Mondays. Yeah. What's going on? Some
people use flowers, some people use that.
Semolina some people use a
mixture of both. I tell you, I,
I like doing it.
I think it goes back to when I was a kid,
I was one those kids like playing in
mud puddles, you know what I mean?
So it was a,
okay,
there's just something about that. I
think that's why like, I like making like,
like pie crust and shit like that.
It's just a big goofy fucking mess.
It's fun. Um, but I'll
definitely, uh, I'll check that
out if I can get online here.
All right.
Cooking Asian food.
Okay.
All right, Bill, how are you?
You freckled cont Jesus. Jesus.
No happy new year. Um,
huge fan from Belgium here.
Nice Bedlam in Belgium.
ACDC flick of the switch album.
How many fucking balls are you
going to drop on Peyton here?
This could be his last game ever.
What are you doing?
Okay.
Jesus Christ. And when did shoulder
pads get so small? Let me see.
Shoulder pads on. People in the
fucking shoulder pads was so big.
The short didn't even cover your belly.
Used to run around with half shirts on,
by the way. Can Grunt, pull his pants
up or get a longer fucking jersey.
You started to look like
a waitress at Hooters.
All right. A huge fan
from Belgium here. Um,
I'm sure it's saying
he showed his midriff.
That's probably the Ron Ron
reference. Who knows, you know,
the little ass country that people know,
uh,
about because of Austin Powers.
Oh,
I thought I knew them from a, I
thought isn't, that's not Brussels.
The muscles from Brussels.
That was the guy who used to,
who's the guy used to do the splits.
Now Fuck is the guy's name.
He wasn't a must break you.
He wasn't.
Steven Seagal was the other guy
from blood splat gives a fuck.
Belgium.
Yeah. Luxembourg and Belgium. Right,
right. They're a tucked in there.
Right there. A battle of the bulge
right there and in France and Germany.
My nuts in between a Amsterdam
in a fucking Denmark.
They're Copenhagen.
You get tucked right there staring
at the fucking a bad teeth of that.
The English,
aren't you looking across the channel?
Maybe not enough. Maybe if I had a
map I could find it. Yeah. All right.
Love Aptis F is for family. Please
come to our, our freckle of a country.
Uh, dude, I'm definitely
going to go there.
I'm definitely going to go there
without a fucking doubt. I'm a,
and we're waiting to hear about the
second season for F is for family.
The pitch went fucking great. Uh, when
out of there, we were all excited.
I got a great feeling about it and I'm
going to let you guys know as soon as I
find out. Um, I got a
good feeling about it.
So, uh, and I'm definitely
going to do a European tour.
I did Australia and Asia last year, so
this time it's time. We had the other way.
I'm going to do a Europe this time and I
want to hit all the countries I've been
to.
I'd like to add a few more and I also
want to do a little bit of eastern Europe,
but, uh, if we do get a second season,
I don't know how many episodes that would
be. I would think it'd be at least 10.
And then,
you know,
we got to sit down and write them and if
we want to make it as good as the first
season, you know, and even
better, which of course we do,
it's gonna take a lot of times. So I
got to kind of figure out, you know, uh,
once they give us the Yay or nay on that.
But like I said, I got a really, really,
really positive vibes. A lot
of laughs in the room and, um,
which is always good. So anyways,
he said, the guy says anyway,
I've heard you talking about
cooking more Asian food. I'll wait.
This is a different one. Um, oh,
it's the same guy. Sorry. And He,
this is the same guy from
Belgium because anyways,
I've heard you talking about wanting
to cook more Asian food on your podcast
since I love cooking as well.
Please allow me to recommend you.
Some Korean cuisine has a
lot of spicy food. Oh yeah.
Kimchi and all that stuff. Um, yeah, I've,
I've been to those Korean barbecue and
all this stuff. I love all of that stuff,
but to, it's just so different from
the stuff here. I'm really intimidated,
um, about cooking it,
uh, which is so stupid,
you know, if I'm on, if I'm afraid of it,
I should just just sit down and be like,
okay, let's start with something easy.
How do you make the sticky rice? You know,
if you could just make sticky rice
alone, that's the shit, right?
That's the best fucking rice there is.
I don't wanna hear everybody
tell me it's not fucking healthy.
I don't give a fuck. You
know, it's fucking delicious.
Korean cuisine has a lot of spicy food,
which is great for losing weight since
you tend to be full more quickly and
drink more water. Plus a lot of other
health benefits. If you are interested,
please check out. Uh, I cannot,
it's m a n G. C H. I on Youtube. Oh,
I've got it. Do this. Uh, I guess
I go, I guess this is a lady.
She's a Korean housewife who
is funny as hell. It learns,
uh, teaches you, you said learns
you how to cook. It's teachers,
teaches you how to cook great
traditional and overall easy recipes.
Now you've got to teach me some Belgian
words. I gave you a one there, Huh? Uh,
recommendations are a Belgium words.
Belgian eum a rep recommendations
are spicy pork stir fry.
Jinxing chicken.
I didn't know how to say this.
It's j. A J. A m. E. O.
N. G. Judge. I'm young.
That sounds like an annoying
character in fucking star wars,
which is black bean sauce,
noodles.
Some other shit that I can't say Korean
barbecue, which I bet you've had before.
Yeah, I have. What does that,
the hacky American thing?
Well, I've had Korean food.
I went to Korea at barbecue.
I literally just said that Japanese
cuisine is mostly salty, sweet,
Umami.
What does Umami mean?
Is that Umami Burger Bender that flavors?
Lots of vegetables.
No butter soy sauce, which is amazing
for you. Enrich, enrich, tastes. Yeah.
I got to tell you mad people
when I went over the age of man,
they will fucking in shape
people adjusted shape over there.
You know?
I bet if you have fat in Asia, they
just mean looking at rich motherfucker.
He must be traveling. He's got
enough money to get to an Applebee's.
I don't fucking a,
I'm too tired.
I didn't want to say Applebee's.
Applebee's is not a fattening places.
It what's a good fat? She said,
I'll just wrap up the podcast. Okay.
If I'm going to be this off right now,
what the fuck's going to happen when I
go to do my shows tonight? All right.
Now Chinese food,
I don't know a lot about.
A cool to know is that Chinese food
in the states and Europe is not actual
Chinese food. No, it isn't.
That's their surreptitious way
of trying to fucking kill us.
That's what they're trying to do. They
know we have the bomb, right. They could,
they, they, that China is attacking
us on two levels right now,
giving us food that's going to give us
a heart attack and they're going to fuck
with our economy somehow.
Somehow we're tied in with them and
they're going to pull the fucking rug out
anyways.
He said modified for our taste buds,
but I'm guessing they have amazing
stuff too. Yeah, I would think.
I would think so.
MMM.
No, fuck am I getting
the hiccups here? Uh,
Thai in Vietnamese food is mostly spring
rolls. Jesus Christ, she'd go, oh,
went through the whole continent here.
MMM.
We get some water. Oh fuck.
Completely missed the glass.
Fucking bad angle here. Um, lastly,
okay. No Thai and Vietnamese.
Mostly spring rolls.
Spicy Curry.
I love our guy from fucking Belgium is
telling me about Asian food or you at
least Asian,
lots of coriander,
which I personally did because
it tasted of dishwasher product,
dishwasher, product. Lastly, if
you really want to go hardcore,
try out North Korean food,
it's basically starving yourself.
You'll be able to see your ginger pube
Ding Dong without a mirror. Again,
in no time, Pretty Edgy, Huh? Yes.
You're making fun of the fact that they
under a dictator that doesn't feed a
very edgy, very edgy, uh,
hope this helped go fuck yourself.
Lots of love for Nia and
old [inaudible] audio. Um,
oh shit. I guess I'll
give the shit, you know,
I love how Asia stops with people that we
can, you know, it doesn't go into India.
That's also Asia, right? Is in the Middle
East. Isn't that also Asia? Russia,
you know. Anyway, I like that guy and
fucking Forrest Gump. Alright. Hey,
Billy Beane,
uh,
been a fan of the podcast for a while now.
Yada Yada.
I need some advice or just a fresh
perspective on what to do. I'm 23.
Ah, yeah. The primary life dropped out
of high school, like a dip shit at 17.
Got My GED when I was 19.
I you back in the game,
you back in the game and he decided to
start becoming a productive member of
society. Everything was going
good. Paycheck meant uh,
the dating pool opened up, tried a
few jobs, et cetera. But now I'm 23.
I quit my job to go to,
to go to school for advertising.
Slash art at an artsy college
should probably mentioned
the only thing I'm truly
good at. His art, mainly
pen and ink stuff.
Well that's a great thing and he can
make a ton of fucking money doing that.
It's just, it's schools generally
speaking, are not geared towards that.
Um,
so yeah,
you will fucking bored and then you
took shit that you weren't good at,
made you feel like an asshole. You fucking
drop out. You partied for a few years.
Right. Bagged a couple of who is
and now you coming back. Dude,
you're fine. You're 23, dude, you're
fine. Uh, that was eight months ago.
I missed the sign.
I missed the sign up date.
And just lack the general knowledge
slash support on going about it.
I spent six months grinding
the living shit out of drawing,
trying to achieve something I might be
able to take some pride in. Didn't work.
I was just going to say, you're being
too hard on yourself. Your next line is,
I'm hard myself to the point where I'm
thinking I'll never be handed a metal is
the greatest that ever fucking
live, so why bother? Ah,
Jesus, dude. Well listen,
Richard Pryor's the greatest of all time
and I'll never come close to that guy.
That does not going to stop me. You
just try to see how close you can come.
Some people you can't pass and
that's all right. You know,
you just try to come as close to them.
Try to just like try to go as high up
the all time ladder as you possibly can,
and who knows? If you keep
pushing yourself, that's it.
You don't know what
your limits are to you.
You keep fucking throwing
yourself out there.
Especially if you're hard on yourself.
You probably be in way.
You're way better than you think you
are. You're going to be fine. All right.
You'd get you're
depressing me here anyway.
I have since quit drawing and now do
nothing but troll around dating sites all
day and hooking up with
semi decent looking women,
women as a way to stay positive
and cure boredom. I'm not lazy.
I've done primarily law,
manual labor jobs and no,
I have the back for,
but Jesus Christ,
I can't force myself to pull the trigger
on anything because I can't be the top
of the crop of the very God damn best.
I want people fulfilled.
I've been standing at a crossroad,
my Dick in my hand for nearly a year and
he's sort of vice be fucking amazing.
Don't hold back. If you think I need to
be ripped a new one, I can handle it.
Thanks. Go Fuck Yourself. Yeah, Dude,
you've got yourself into a completely
paralyzed state here because it's like you
got it. You just bought a guitar and
because you're not Jimmy Hendrix,
within the first two weeks, you're
going to fucking quit. All right.
If Jimi Hendrix did that, he
wouldn't be Jimi Hendrix. All right.
All right.
And they'd look just
okay
if you,
whatever you like to do in life,
just go out and do it all right and
enjoy it and don't put that level of
pressure on yourself.
Okay.
Like what was your, was your dad like
the Great Santini is something that,
I'm trying to figure out why
you like this, but like, um,
the reason why he can't pull the trigger
on anything else in life is because you
actually have a strong,
I think you have a strong sense on what
makes you happy and what you want to do.
All right.
And you know that despite the fact that
you'd be totally negative but you're
drawing,
you know that that's what you want to do
and you have such a passion for it that
you're that hard on yourself.
And then also it's preventing you from
getting a job at the fucking Costco or
wherever the God damn place you're
going to end up fucking working at. Um,
okay.
I would, I don't know if I was
you, I would continue drawing.
I get into computers and all that.
There's all kinds of stuff.
I've seen people do drugs on computers,
and they turned that
into building websites,
which helps to pay for that their studio
and the shit that they really want to
do this. There's tons of money
to making the arts. Don't,
don't let anybody ever fucking tell
you that there isn't it did you?
Just helping people make
it in show business.
All right?
This p people will get head shots,
give acting classes and all that.
Just doing that shit.
People make a small fucking fortunate.
So if you actually a talented artists,
you can actually, you're
going to be fine. Um,
you just have to stop beating the shit
out of yourself. All right? So, uh,
just pay attention to
that voice in your head.
And when it tells you
you can't do something,
just tell it to shut the
fuck up basically. Even if
you have to say it out loud,
you don't just make sure you're not
looking at somebody you care about as
they're telling you a story. When you
think of those thoughts, just, you know,
maybe, maybe say it in your
brain first. All right? Okay.
Advice. No one to relate to cheeses.
He's a fucking gloomy this week.
All right. Advice. No one to relate
to causing loading loneliness.
Okay.
All right. Hey, Billy batts
love the podcasts you stand
up after it's her family.
Uh, they all put a smile on my
face. Well, that's great. Okay.
I'm sensing that all of a sudden
now the smile is going to go away.
I hope you read this because he had under
my problem is I have no one to relate
to and I fear I might
as well read this year.
I hope you read this because I've
been doing everything positive,
but I just can't seem to get
my life where I want it to be.
It's a bit of a long road, so please bear
with me. Oh, fuck us. It's a long email
dude. You know, I can't read out loud.
Okay.
All right.
My problem is I have no one to relate to
and I fear I might be co this might be
causing me
to be lonely in life.
I fear that if I continue the way
I'm going, I may never get over.
I'm in my last semester of college and
an engineering program and if made almost
no friends throughout my
entire stay at college,
I am at the top of my classes and I'm
lining up jobs at big tech companies.
Now you're probably managing some point
extra with the pocket pocket protector
and all that. Actually
I was, that's exactly,
that was the picture you were painting,
sir. Uh, quite the opposite actually.
I had been working out for a few years
now and I have one and I am one of the
Jack to people in my classes.
All right.
So now a picture is that
dude in American psycho,
highly achieving, totally shredded,
cannot relate to human beings.
Um, I dress well, eat healthy. Please
tell me you don't listen to Huey,
a Huey Lewis and the news.
Um,
and always make sure to keep myself clean.
I feel like I might alienate my
classmates from interacting with me.
They probably think I'm just a jock in
their class where it's quite the opposite.
I'm into gaming,
chess and all of that though.
Do you like a fucking
a renaissance man here?
So I figure I might try to
interact with the opposite crowd,
the Non Geeky people.
I know a way to meet people is to get out
there and do something. I I like doing,
playing some sport or joining
a club or volunteering.
The problem is with my
PR program and my work,
I have little time to be doing much else.
The free time I have is Friday or Saturday
nights that I spent by myself playing
video games or playing guitar because
I have nothing else to do. Well,
you could go out those nights.
Okay.
All right. It wasn't always
this way. This is like a movie.
When I was in high school,
my life was completely the
opposite. I didn't work out,
eat healthy, work hard or nothing, but
I always find ways to make new friends,
make people laugh and start conversations.
Now that I'm doing everything right,
it seems my only problem is
social. Oh Jesus Christ. Dude.
So you know what you're doing. You just
too busy. I fear once I graduate college,
things will only get worse. I
lost all of my faith, my family,
apart from my older brother
who was in another country.
So once I graduate college,
I'll truly be alone.
No one to grab a beer with no one to help
me move or anything helped me move or
anything.
Despite all this,
I try to be positive and thankful for
what I have and what I have accomplished.
Sorry for the long email and go fuck
yourself. Yeah, Dude. You just look,
you already know how to make friends. I
would, you need to make time to do it. Um,
played video games by yourself is very
antisocial. Uh, playing guitars. Always.
Cool. That's fun. Why don't you play
guitar with somebody else? Find somebody,
plays drums. I play Bass. Get
together, do some covers, you know,
jam. Fuck around. Get
off, drink some beers.
Invite some ladies over. You do every
week you just add some more shit, right?
You know, start taking bets. Open your
own fucking a draft kinks. You know,
maybe start selling coke.
Just keep expanding your
ring of a social interaction.
I'm obviously fucking with
you, but no, I would, uh,
there's a bunch of people
that are into video games.
Why don't you find somebody that you can
play against? Can you do that anymore?
The kids do that or do you have
to go online to do it? You know,
is that like Corny?
Now doesn't two people not sit next to
each other with an Atari with a joy stick
and the one red button is, are we
past that? I don't fucking know,
but it seems like you know how to do
that stuff. He just got busy. And, uh,
with all your achievements, you,
you know, sometimes, you know,
when you go after a goal,
some things suffer. All right.
I've talked about this numerous
times when I was on, um,
you know,
when I was 36 years old though,
I was fucking living alone in a studio
apartment that they called the one
bedroom, sleeping on a futon. I
remember days just going by going,
what the fuck have I done?
The only thing I've worked on
is trying to become a comedian.
Everything else is at the starting
line. And, uh, over the next 10 years,
I just worked on some shit like that.
So that's all you need to do. All right.
Jesus Christ. I'm starting to feel
like doctor Phil here. Um, all right.
What do we got here?
Third and goal?
Broncos have the ball with three minutes
left and I'll do an a fucking podcast.
Touchdown Broncos.
Okay.
All right.
Broncos ne go celebrate and act like
a bunch of fucking idiots when Ben
Roethlisberger has three minutes left.
Okay.
This one is not over. All right. So what
does this do? This puts them up by five
people in the crowd
holding up two fingers.
Like the crowd's going to look at them.
Oh yeah. Yeah. We should go for two,
shouldn't we? We shouldn't just be
up by six. Thank you. Thank you.
The you and the fucking a
mezzanine level. Ah, fuck.
Okay.
Are we gonna have to go to Denver?
Is this going to be one more?
One more break? Either way.
This is going to be great.
Either you get to see Brady versus
Peyton manning. One more time.
Okay.
I'm assuming he's retiring,
which is stupid. Or you get
to see another patriots,
a Steelers matchup with fucking big Ben.
Big Bad. Not Afraid of anything. Big
Bed, both grade teams. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
I apologize that my head was
kind of all over the place.
I don't know what flying and going
to the fucking airport does to me.
MMM.
But, uh, it makes me even more
fucking scatter brained. So anyways,
go fuck yourself and I will talk to
you on Thursday. Okay. All right.